[Música]
continuamos aquí en directo América con
directo a y Vamos hasta Caracas la
capital venezolana porque un día de que
el gobierno y un sector de la oposición
retomen diálogos el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro volvió a condenar la detención de
Alexa un presunto testaferro de Maduro
que fue extraditado a Estados Unidos los
delegados exigieron su Liberación para
que se una prontamente al equipo
negociador del ejecutivo conectamos con
Daniela Zambrano corresponsal de Franz
24 en Caracas Daniela ambas partes
emitieron comunicados previos al
encuentro qué detalles se conocen y qué
se espera de la primera jornada de
negociaciones mañana
ya está en suelo mexicano la delegación
del gobierno de Nicolás maduro
encabezada por Jorge Rodríguez
presidente además de la asamblea
nacional lo acompaña el hijo de Nicolás
maduro Nicolás Maduro Guerra y en esta
oportunidad se incorpora precisamente al
equipo negociador del gobierno Camila
fabres de saab esposa del empresario
colombiano alexad como decías detenido
extraditado por Estados Unidos acusado
por lado de activos pero que el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro considera y señala
como diplomático venezolano secuestrado
por el gobierno estadounidense la
exigencia de su Liberación que se
incorpore a la mesa y también por parte
del gobierno está la exigencia del
levantamiento de las sanciones Jorge
Rodríguez a través de la red social
Twitter de adelantaba que este 26 de
noviembre se firmaría un acuerdo social
parcial con la oposición venezolana sin
embargo no daba detalles pero ha
trascendido que se trataría de este
acuerdo Social para ayuda humanitaria
Venezuela para liberar fondos cercanos a
tres mil millones de dólares que serían
administrados por la organiza de
Naciones Unidas se está a la espera que
arriba a México la delegación venezolana
encabezada de la oposición venezolana
encabezada por Gerardo Blade a través de
un comunicado ellos ya adelantaban que
buscaban además construcción de
condiciones para elecciones libres y
observables y que la crisis de Venezuela
no se iba a solventar sin un acuerdo
político llama la atención además que
previo a este encuentro Jorge Rodríguez
Ya adelantaba que la oposición y el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro tienen entre
4 y 5 meses con conversaciones secretas
y discretas precisamente para discutir
ese acuerdo social que se firmaría este
sábado en México una vez se reúnan las
partes Daniel a otro tema que centra la
atención son las conversaciones entre el
gobierno colombiano y la guerrilla de
lln de las que Venezuela es garante que
avances se han presentado
este viernes hubo un comunicado que fue
presentado no fue convocada la prensa
nuevo pregunta por parte de los medios
de comunicación simplemente se limitaron
a leer un comunicado en el que acordaron
Tres puntos el primero se trataba de los
países garantes ratificar a Venezuela
Noruega y Cuba como países garantes Pero
además incorporar a Brasil a chile y a
México en el proceso llamó la atención
que las partes también acordaron
adelantar acciones diplomáticas para
invitar a Estados Unidos a que se
incorpore en este proceso de
negociaciones mediante el envío de un
delegado especial también se invitó a
los países Suecia Suiza Alemania y
España a ser parte del proceso como
acompañantes se habló además de posibles
liberaciones no se especificó con estas
palabras se hablaba específicamente
acciones de dinámicas humanitarias sin
embargo podía interpretarse que se
trataría de liberaciones de Rehenes y
excarcelación de guerrilleros y el
tercer punto sería que se conforma un
equipo de comunicaciones para informar
oportunamente de estos avances estas
conversaciones se van a extender hasta
mediados de diciembre en Caracas según
la anunciaron en un primer comunicado